so the Toronto Raptors return to the
court tonight to face the heat and it's
a good thing the game is played again in
Miami because some people are still
losing their minds at what Dwyane Wade
did during the Canadian national anthem
on Sunday yeah he kept doing his regular
routine shooting baskets during the
warmup not paying attention to what was
going on and not standing at attention
here's what you have to say I'm not a
disrespectful person so if anybody think
I'm being disrespectful to a country
then they have no idea who's doing
anyway it is but you know you have to
make it you have to make an adjustment
without pregame ritual
if anybody feel like it was please don't
fill up my timeline with disrespectful
comments because uh that's not this guy
right here you can find somebody else
with that okay first of all don't talk
about yourself in the third person
didn't do that and second add the word
soaring in there it would have made a
huge difference otherwise it's rude and
I understand rituals but come on by the
way we want so the originals didn't
really work the Miami Heat organizers
are think they really did blow it
because they did start early and
everyone else stopped and respected the
anthem and this is actually a violation
of an NBA rule which requires everyone
to quote line up in a dignified posture
along the sidelines I can't wait to find
out what's gonna happen on Wednesday
when he shows up in Toronto I think
every time he throws a three-pointer the
fans are gonna be seen your own Canada I
think that's a really good idea however
on our Facebook page Clarins is
completely buying what Wade is selling
this guy is well-respected around the
league and one of the best known
athletes around the world
he does a lot of Miami this guy's a
classic mm-hmm but nan says wow I can
just hear the Americans that this had
been the other way around they would
have gone ballistic show some respect
see I think good people do bad things he
says a bad thing now our viewers on
Twitter we're upset to Kerry tweets this
guy needs to be fine and suspend
and then forced to learn our national
and brilliant and Dora says no apology
dude you're shooting hoops while
everyone else is respecting me anthem
apologize at least so arrogant or is one
of our co-workers suggested making
recorded Johnny Depp's apology video
that's great